there's lots of uh debate and there has
been over time
about if and when and whether it's ever
okay
to make an analogy to hitler and to
nazis and the analogies
often are not warranted they don't make
sense they're not well calibrated to
what we're looking at in the modern day
however on fox news a few days ago judge
jeanine pirro
went on a rant about hispanic immigrants
that is almost identical to the language
that we saw from nazis
and other anti-semites about jews in the
past
listen to what judge janine pirro had to
say
now who've got coven wait a minute let
me listen to you you listen to me
they've got coven they've got all kinds
of diseases
they are being released into the united
states now you're not going to tell me
that a governor is going to shut me down
and not allow me to do my
job and let any illegals because we've
got a heart
they have all sorts of diseases and
they're being released the way you would
release an
animal into the wild they're being
released into the united states
this is typical third reich anti-semitic
rhetoric used to justify the
genocide of jews during world war ii
replacing
jews with hispanic immigrants in the
story
it's the same language i'm not saying
judge jeanine is hitler i'm saying this
language is the same
now you can even actually go back beyond
world war ii for this
if you go back to the black plague in
england
it was blamed on jews by anti-semites
the blaming
jews for disease is a really old thing
but if you look at third reich
propaganda specifically the
justification for the cleansing of the
population
was based on the idea of an alien race
of jews poisoning the culture bringing
disease
this exact type of thing we're seeing
from judge jeanine now again
as i mentioned last week even this type
of rhetoric
when you talk about coronavirus is
nonsense because the u.s
has a significantly higher per capita
case rate than mexico
there's no reason to think that covid is
coming from mexico
to the united states we have way more of
it here but ignore that for now
this type of defiant sounding
anger from judge jeanine was the same
type of thing
applied to jews during hitler's germany
the dehumanization is present
in so many genocides you look at the
rwandan genocide as another example
i recently read a very good book about
the rwandan
genocide by philip gorovich excellent
disturbing but excellent book
the kernel of an idea that started the
genocide
and there's a lot of colonial uh forces
that that
sort of were involved in the creation of
this idea the idea was
that the hutus and the tutsis were
not only clearly distinct ethnic groups
but one was sub-human
one was dirty one was unrefined and
unsophisticated
and the hutus decided that the tutsis
were inferior
and they were off to the races with the
disgusting genocide
as i mentioned in our segment about the
fox news
focus on the border last week and will
again
this week during gen saki's pres saki's
press briefings
this is what they found as their new
punching bag
trump leaves and biden comes in the
country
has given joe biden the highest initial
approval for a president in nearly 30
years
70 percent want coveted relief 80
agree with joe biden's federal mass
mandate for transportation and federal
offices vaccination has
tripled since joe biden took over the
world is moving on from trump
so they have cultural issues like dr
seuss and supposed cancer culture and
now they've fixated
on the border which shouldn't surprise
us because this has been their playbook
for a long time
remember talking about a migrant caravan
leading up to the 2018 midterms
the day after the 2018 election we don't
hear about a migrant caravan
until october of 2020 when they need
that again
and part of this is also strategic
texas and mississippi are opening wide
open
even though health officials say it's
too early to do that they're getting rid
of mass mandates they're getting rid of
everything
ending that right now is likely to cause
a search
and they are preemptively on the attack
against hispanic immigrants to be able
to blame
them when the surge hits in places like
texas
judge jeanine obviously should be fired
for this
but is fox news going to fire her when
the audience loves this stuff
probably not so i would expect judge
jeanine
maybe she'll get a promotion and a raise
for this rant which even if you watch
the video
she was alongside geraldo there even
geraldo
looked perplexed and sort of distraught
to the extent that he's able to
uh during that absolutely outrageous
rant
one of our sponsors is susman and han
sussman and han has
everything you need when it comes to
face masks and other supplies
to stay safe during covid19 and susman
and han
is the company that i've personally been
going to
for face masks and other ppe because i
trust the products that they sell and
that's actually why we reached out to
them about becoming a sponsor because
their prices are reasonable ordering is
simple
everything ships within 24 hours and
they just have
high quality products for this global
hundred year pandemic they've got
surgical masks kn 95 masks
n95 masks other useful things like
infrared thermometers face shields
sanitizers
sussman and han is also an awesome
company because they've donated
over 65 000 masks so far to health care
institutions
shipping is free on orders over a
hundred and fifty dollars you can go to
their website by going to
davidpakman.com
mask the link is right underneath this
video and they'll give you 20
off when you use the coupon code david